bonsoir michel à l'orée de là ce soir
pour nous présenter karine lyachenko qui
cartonne en ce moment au point virgule
dans un spectacle dont vous avez assuré
la mise en scène elle nous rejoindra à
la fin de son spectacle
alors on vous voit moins en ce moment
sur les plateaux de télé vous dites
c'est un petit peu fatigué de faire le
clown mais c'est à dire qu'on considère
toujours assez mal les gens qui viennent
faire de la télévision régulièrement un
mois j'espère que j'ai surfé date et que
j'aimais bien j'avais bien offert et
puis on me l'a reproché enfin pas le
public mais les médias un grand voir les
médias et professionnels à la russie
vous trotter l'espagne à gnagnagna bon
l'image est tout bon bref donc j'ai un
peu calmer la bête ouais en plus moi je
suis une enfant de la télé je veux dire
j'ai commencé chez bouvard et tout ça
donc c'est vraiment un endroit où j'aime
dans lequel je me sens très très bien et
on me l'a reproché et en même temps ça
m'a aidé parce que quand quand j'ai
monté démon de midi on a monté une
petite boîte de prod et les sous qu'on
allait chercher on me les a données
parce que c'était aussi michel dernier
qu'on voyait un peu partout et voilà on
m'aurait vu nulle part ben non alors le
démon de midi s'est terminée c'est
dommage d'ailleurs parce qu'elle comme
la pièce le dvd le film alors jeté sympa
vous veniez régulièrement les ouïes
bachelin son toupet maintenant aux
barbies et de cornes
les produits dérivés oui alors on va
vous revoir quand même beaucoup à la
rentrée puisque vous allez remonter sur
scène aux bouffes parisiens vous avez
joué le démon de 13 heures sur la vie
sexuelle de jean pierre pernaut alors ça
va pas être simple est ce qu a eu
beaucoup de rebondissements cet été donc
je dois appeler jean pierre pour qu'ils
me donnent deux trois trucs j'avais lu
le bouquin non parce que je n'ai pas le
temps c'est une pièce de stephen king
qui s'appelle dolores claiborne c'est
l'histoire d'une femme qui prend en
otage un écrivain pas du tout
[Rires]
c'est avec les mains je prends les
flamands de clarin avoir c'est bien
stephen king et lorsque les bornes n'est
pas misery un voile a misé lui c'est
effectivement une femme qui prend en
otage à l'écrivain est ce qu elle veut
qu'ils continuent à écrire des romans à
l'eau de rose à qui veut plus écrit il
c'est pas çà et là ça n'a strictement
rien à voir non en fait c'est l'histoire
d'une femme qui est accusée d'avoir tué
sa patronne c'est presque par la nuit
celle enfin kazim kazim enfin voilà donc
c'est une histoire à la fois
un peu noir un peu à peu ce thriller et
en même temps plein d'humanité parce que
c'est une femme c'est une femme simple
et c'est une femme qu'à son franc parler
qui est et puis qui un jour a décidé de
de venger sa fille voilà donc c'est une
belle histoire de l'histoire alors voila
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec mise lui
qui est une très belle pièce aussi il
faudrait aussi mais écoutez je l'avais
déjà il faut gérer puisque sa balle à
moi voilà comme ça tu reprendras
alors la mise en scène est toujours
assurée par la même personne pascale
osterrieth voilà je te dis pour toi
parce que j'aurai c'est que voilà tu
t'obstines a bossé avec cette gonzesse
dont j'arrive pas à dire le nom parce
que je regarde ça nous un petit truc
comme ça oui c'est vrai marie pascale
osterrieth s appellerait
oui cela and i was
alors on vous voit moins dans les talk
shows mais on vous voit beaucoup en
prime time dans des fictions notamment
les frangines avec arielle dombasle
malahide acte et on est en train de
faire la suite voilà donc vous est la
demi-soeur d'arielle dombasle ce qui est
absolument génial maintenant ah bon
pourquoi ah ben on a changé nous ont
fait un peu le couple un peu centre de
comparaison prétentieuse mais c'est un
peu dans la verve de webber avec
depardieu et et pierre richard c'est à
dire qu'ils avaient à chaque fois on le
couple reste mais il vit autrement et on
n'est pas tout le temps 10 heures voilà
parce que la première fois vous étiez
quand même l'un des commissaires oui
elle était mannequin et voiceover
mannequin pour cheveux voilà si on
n'agit pas il ya des gens ils sont
moches maison des beaux cheveux
plus beau
c'est ce qu'ont fait jouer toutes les
deux maintenant n'importe quoi c'est
quand même parce que d'abord il ya une
complicité qui s'est installée entre
nous deux j'adore cette femme on s'aime
vraiment profondément et notre
complicité et de fait quoi je renais
toutes les deux ça que ça fonctionne ça
marche et vous avez lu le bouquin de
bain marie mais non parce que j'ai pas
le temps de lire les livres à lire parce
qu'elle raye pas que c'est vachement
bien ça c'est qu'ariel à la main
sûrement que vous le lisiez quand même
bah oui mais je vais je vais lire en
anglais voilà on va très bien voilà
comme ça ça lui fera un bouquin de
vendus là bas et vous quel shelly
boubou quatre célibataires ça vous
saoule pas qu ariel parle sans arrêt de
bernard henri bernard alors moi je suis
fasciné par ces couples qui sont
amoureux comme ça le plus de vingt ans
quand on les voit tous les deux dans la
vie privée sont des gens qui s'aiment
d'un amour profond de cottance très beau
à voir et quand c'est beau à voir comme
ça je suis encore plus jaloux
vous vous dites l'amour ça va ça vient
j'ai l'impression d'être devenue une
adolescente
ouais c'est vrai je suis je suis dans en
fait eu dans la peau d'une ado
je vis un peu une vie dragueuse comme on
est à 17 18 ans et en même temps j'ai la
majorité de mon âge donc c'est un peu
curieux c'est à dire que quand je me
vois en boîte avec l chupa chups bien un
truc qui va pas
est ce que c'est si désagréable que ça
d'être célibataire
ça dépend des jours il ya des jours où
on aimerait bien avoir quelqu'un avec
qui partager deux trois trucs même des
trucs pas intéressant derrière mais et
puis ya des fois où après tout c'est pas
si mal puis moi je suis heureux je suis
gâté j'ai deux enfants magnifiques ça va
quoi c'est difficile de rencontrer un
homme sur lequel on peut compter quand
même non bah ouais ils sont ils sont
frileux les gars aujourd'hui alors que
là il ya un problème c'est qu'en fait
les mecs de mon âge à peu près ils
viennent de larguer la même que moi oui
oui bah oui donc ils vont pas s'y
remettre ils vont chercher la petite
dannatt 25 balles et un salaire ça leur
donne l'impression de rajeunir donc
après il faut que j'attende le temps
qu'ils s'emmerdent avec la petite
ça veut dire que ça me fait arriver les
maires 60 balais quoi si je le prends à
60 à 65 commence à prendre ses gouttes
pour son arthrose
bon j'ai pas envie de poser le fauteuil
trop tôt donc après qu'on s'est trop
jeune bon genre 30 balais je veux dire
quand même franchement un peu jeune un
bon alors mais on s'ennuie vite avec un
jeune aussi parce que bon après la même
sympa je raconte un bon ça raconte des
trucs sous la couette sympa mais il n'y
a pas que ça dans
donc c'est un peu compliqué à mon âge il
faut que je trouve un espèce de martiens
voilà j'ai pas il est peut-être cacher
quelques pas sur mon problème
aujourd'hui des princes charmants c'est
que à partir d'un certain âge il
n'arrive pas tout seul avec le cheval il
ya la carriole
[Applaudissements]
ah les mecs
on va faire une interview aux années
mais
est ce qu'un de vos mac a déjà eu envie
de coucher avec votre meilleure amie
moi si je le savais j'ai répété la tête
un bon l'important c'est que ma
meilleure amie et plus envie de coucher
c'est vrai est ce qu'un mec a déjà une
panne d'érection en votre présence
ouais ouais ouais
vous faites quoi dans ces cas là michel
ces cas là je pars
ou partaient au oui/non le court c'est
pas grave ça arrive à tout et on
inquiète pas non cette place histoire
tombe cette année un raid accord
avec la mairie puis le temps mois
attend à 18 en a le temps de discuter
trois heures dans un puma rivoire voir
gnagna moi j'ai pu le temps c est ce qu
un mec a essayé de cacher vous étiez sa
copine devant ses potes oh non non non
quand même pas pourquoi il aurait honte
de moi non je sais pas non est ce qu'un
mec j'ai déjà rappelé juste pour baiser
un soir comme ça
ouais ouais vous faites quoi dans ce cas
là c'est pas ce qui me passionne fait je
trouve ça désagréable juste le halo
alors tu étais était dispo ça me gêne
j'aime bien qu'on aille un petit peu mon
resto savent pas trop quoi chez les
filles on aime bien un peu que ce soit
un peu qu'un petit truc tendresse un peu
quelque chose même si on sait que ça va
pas durer mais bon c'est agréable d'être
regardée
en lumière est ce qu'un mec ja déjà
quitter du jour au lendemain sans
explication mais
il se reconnaîtra
est ce qu'un mec a déjà tout fait pour
vous le quittez vous à ça sinon s'amuser
n'arrive jamais non non généralement ils
n'aiment vraiment à la folie et puis un
jour hop ça leur passe
est ce qu'un mec est déjà simuler un
orgasme avec vous je sais même pas que 6
à 6 mai chez les garçons ça si bien sûr
ballard je n'ai pas vu donc c'était bien
c'est mame awa sûrement bien sûr est ce
qu'un mec j'ai déjà appelé par un autre
prénom pendant que vous faisiez l'amour
non non non non non toujours minées way
des fois j'ai eu des mecs qui avaient
les des femmes et qui avait le même
prénom que moi ça c'est bien que c'est
pratique ça c'est appréciable est ce
qu'un mec a déjà essayé d'abuser de vous
alors que vous étiez ivre
je ne suis jamais ivre voilà donc
comment enfin vous
êtes vous je sais pas quand je dors très
bien ce même jour à travers 13 ans là
est-ce qu'un mec vous a déjà promis
qu'il allait bientôt quitter sa femme
pour vous ah oui bien sûr pas ça c'est
tout le temps oui beaucoup s'attendaient
d'ailleurs toujours avec
est ce qu'un mec j'ai déjà appelé
bobonne ah non ok le hongre ces pages
vous demandera non non non
pas resté assez longtemps ont peut-être
pour avoir ce nom là est ce qu'un mec
est déjà critiqué votre manière de
cuisiner
permet du sel mais critique pas je
cuisine pas extrêmement bien en plus
donc je comprends est ce qu'un mec a
déjà essayé d expliquer la bonne manière
pour faire l'amour
non pas spécialement non
sinon ça va je suis à plus tôt ça va je
suis très à l'aise ouais ouais
ouais j'ai une bonne nature à excuse et
déjà surpris un nouveau mac en train de
se masturber quelle question c'est un
plus vous ouvrez la porte de la salle de
bain à ce que je suis dans la salle de
bain
non dans les chiottes quand on est petit
j'espère qu'il l'a fait quand j'étais
pas là non ça extrêmement avec ça vous
plairait pas à ça non pas d'accord est
ce qu'un mec vous a déjà reproché d'être
trop chaude au lit
un mec reproches et saina n'abaisserait
pas bien lui
est ce qu'un mec vous a déjà dit qu'il
préférait que vous restiez ami oh oui ah
je déteste ça parce que je dis toujours
des amis j'en ai déjà
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'un mec il a déjà proposé un
plan à plusieurs
à oui mais alors j'aime pas du tout ah
non j'ai pas essayé non non non non mais
non non non non non non non qu'est ce
qui vous énerve c'est un mec mal aimé
qui chauffe
parce qu'on parle toujours des
allumeuses moi je dis souvent quand les
mecs choses dites à un chippendale toi
ouais en fait on passe la soirée entre
gare et puis on se rentre à la maison
tout seul car assez j'aime pas et les
chauffeurs ça m'énerve par quoi peut-on
très bien remplacer un mec pas rien ah
oui ah ouais pareil un appareil non non
non non non non non non il faut nancy
bien non c'est bien les mecs c'est bien
moi je suis pas anti mecque du tout et
je les aime beaucoup moins avec quoi
peut-on être
voilà qui compte
avec quoi peut-on rattraper un mec
si je le savais ouais si je le savais
mais je serai mais envahi non mais je
sais pas du tout aujourd'hui je sais
plus qui veulent en fait qu'à une époque
bon quand on est jeune on se dit ils ont
envie de construire une famille de
d'avancer dans la vie après un certain
âge aux is high et socialement c'est
arrivé qu est ce qui leur ferait plaisir
aujourd'hui on sait pas est-ce qu'il
faut être une fille intelligente est ce
qu'il faut être une andouille est-ce
qu'il faut être jolie pas jolie et ce
qui s'en foutent il ya plein de
paramètres aujourd'hui qui sont
extrêmement compliquées pour savoir
qu'est ce qui plaît à un homme
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui donne le plus
envie de devenir lesbienne
yad abord aux noms pourquoi vous n'avez
jamais essayé non non puis non pas
pourquoi vous pouvez dire vous aimé
parce que vous n'avez jamais essayé mais
parce que ça me dit rien je vais me
forcer
non non non non non moi j'aime la
différence donc jamais très décalé
voilà et les garçons sont nichons si
c'est possible
oui
[Musique]
un
deux trois quarts
normal me fait peur elle là je vous dis
il raconte même pas
perdre du poids on a faim de l'émission
ah bah écoute et je viens de perdre 8
kilos ah bon comment saab on
garde
encore encore important depuis que après
la peu près l'âge de 15 ans j'ai dû
perdre 3000 kg vient donc un peu plus un
peu moins
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il mettait un peu
de bleu